[Music]
commission has concluded exploratory
talks with the pharmaceutical company
valeneva to purchase its potential
vaccine against kovite 19.
under the envisaged contract all eu
member states could purchase up to 30
million doses
with an option for an additional 30
million
more today's finalization of the
exploratory talks with
valeneva complements our already broad
portfolio of vaccines
to be produced in europe and which
includes contracts signed with
astrazeneca
with sanofi gsk yansa pharmaceutical
bantek pfizer kurovak and moderna
and also exploratory talks which we
finalized with
novavax as usual you will find more
information on this
on our in the press release and on our
press quarter thank you
thank you very much this concludes
our announcement and i passed the floor
to
isabel silva isabel you have the floor
hello good morning do you hear me well
go ahead so i would like to ask a
question
regarding the yemen situation does the
eu
regret the fact that the united states
decided to designate the utis as a
foreign terrorist
group and in light of that should the eu
revise
its role in creating peace and stability
in yemen
thank you thank you
thank you very much this is a question
clearly for peter thank you indeed we
noted this decision by the united states
it's not the decision by the european
union and
we are preparing a statement on the
issue so we will issue it in the course
of the day
thank you are there other foreign
relations
related questions for uh peter
today please only keep your hand raised
if this is
um the case
and i see that atanasius has a question
atenesios
thanks very much mozur
finally the exploratory talks between
turkey and greece are announced
there is an offer from the turkey side
which is accepted
by the greek site what is your comment
on this and
would you consider it useful that uh
european union observer
might also participate in this talks is
there
such an option did you ever discuss this
potential option with any of the other
actors thanks
thank you athanasio as well this is a
bilateral issue we were discussing
already how important it is uh
for turkey to behave constructively
towards the eu member states because the
eu has
on numerous occasions stressed its
solidarity with greece
with cyprus and stressed also the need
to solve all the bilateral issues
and the eu is ready to do whatever is
needed for our
member states if they ask us to support
them in any other way
you know the the eu is a community of
like-minded countries which support each
other and solidarity is a key word
so if greece decides that they need uh
support from the eu
in this bilateral talks with turkey
i think the greek partners know what
they need to do in order to get such
support but
i can only recall how strong and how
clear the eu was in expressing
solidarity
with greece in this particular case and
the need to solve all the issues which
are between greece and turkey
behind the negotiating table so it's
good if the announcements and intentions
will be finally translated into concrete
actions and negotiations
thank you are there other questions for
peter related to
um eu relations with turkey thomas
i don't believe that your question is on
this please only keep your hand raised
if the question is
on on turkey eu relations
that does not seem to be the case
so i now go to thomas
thank you very much i hope you hear me
well the swiss
president gipper milan has given
affection
francis samuel president review
donald trump
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
clarification
[Music]
yes thank you i would like to ask your
reaction to the announcement by israel
yesterday
to build 800 new housing units
in occupied west bank thank you
peter thank you we understand that this
has been announcement and
it has not been normalized yet uh
formalized yet sorry but
it doesn't change our long-standing
position the eu is fundamentally opposed
to
the settlements the building and
enlarging settlements they are illegal
from the point of
view of the international law and
uh they also constitute an obstacle
in the peace process they constitute an
obstacle in
building trust between israelis and
palestinians and they also constitute a
huge obstacle to building the
or to the two-state solution and the
european union
calls on israel to hold these activities
and to focus on offering a vision of
restarting the talks and rebuilding the
trust
instead of continuing the settlement
expansions and building of settlements
which are illegal
on the international law
thank you are there other questions for
peter on external affairs
today i see two hands raised patricia
thank you eric good morning i would like
to know
if tomorrow when secretary of state
pompeo will be in town will meet
uh high representative borrel or
somebody else from
the eu commission
thank you
the answer is no that was easy
um any other questions for us on foreign
affairs
today i do not see any so
i opened the floor again and i think
that oliver had raised his hand
oliver patricia sorry you have a
follow-up
on this
strange that nobody in in the eu
commission
is going to meet he never
asked or uh i'm sorry patricia but
we're not in the process of uh debating
you know the requests that we get the
answers that we gave etc
the fact is that there is no meeting
planned between
secretary of state pompeo and members of
the college
oliver you have the floor
hello hi hello
uh yeah i would have questions on uh
vaccination and this
vaccination certificate that uh the
greek prime minister suggested in the
letter to you
according to uh politico but could you
maybe
first take peter's question on the
financing of the slovenian news
why because that seems quite urgent and
she can't sign up to your
um through the intactio uh
conferencing thing so maybe if you could
answer her question first and then we
get back to the
vaccination um thing where there's gonna
be
further questions as well i guess oliver
that's very very gentlemanly of you to
pass the floor to uh to petra
indeed who seems to be having mic
problems today so
with your permission we will indeed then
take her
take her question if there is consensus
on the fact that it is very urgent so
i will read to you the question as we
have received that
um how when and by whom
will the decision
be taken regarding the financing of the
sta so the slovenian news agency
will be determined whether this
financing whether the conditions are met
whether the compensation can be granted
without prior approval of the commission
and is the commission investigating the
case will it produce the opinion on it
or not
can you please clarify regarding the
procedure i believe that these questions
were already
answered yesterday i passed the floor
again
to ariana to see if she can say anything
else
hi eric hi petra i hope you can hear me
and and and see me so uh perhaps i can
add a couple of words with respect to
what i have said yesterday
as i had mentioned but just to recall in
general stated rules do enable member
states to grant aid
to press agencies as compensation for
services of general economic interest
and let me be clear european rules
cannot serve as an excuse to stop the
funding of
press agencies across the eu clearly
based on the available information
the amounts of financing for the
slovenian press
agency are within the limits laid down
in eu legislation furthermore slovenia
has not
indicated that any other relevant
conditions specified in the rules for a
state aid
for compensation of services of general
economic interest
are would not be met therefore it
appears
that the aid could be granted without
the need of a prior notification to and
approval by the commission
thank you very much now
oliver we come back to you on vaccines
yeah uh could you could you give us uh
an outline of your thinking about this
proposal by the greek prime minister to
introduce
a european vaccination certificate
uh that would you know make it easier to
board a plane
uh probably also to um you know enter
public spaces
um and i have another question
vaccination as well but maybe we take
this one this one first
thank you yeah before i pass to stefan
let me point out
that the fact that the letter has been
published
in a media does not mean that we have
actually received it
it seems and as things turned out we
have received the letter formally only
late
late morning so obviously we are in the
process of analyzing
the content but i passed the floor to to
stefan
on the issue more generally and to
christian
yes thank you um maybe in addition to
what
eric said um you know that the topics
which have been raised in this letter in
addition to other topics relating to the
rollout of the vaccination
will be discussed in the context of the
european council with the heads of state
and so we it's of course important that
we look for the outcome of the
discussions in the context of this
meeting this important meeting that we
will be in a position
to indeed analyze and reply to the
letter that has been received from the
prime minister
thank you oliver you had a second
question on vaccines
yeah i mean um regardless of the letter
of the the greek prime minister this
debate around some sort of
vaccination passport or certificate
isn't new so i assume
you have some general lines of thinking
about this
uh could you give us an idea of whether
you think it would be a good idea
to maybe even discuss it or do you think
it's a bad idea because it would
discriminate between people who are
vaccinated and those who are not
given especially since it's going to
take quite some time until everyone
gets a gets a shot and then i have
another question vaccination but let's
take this first name
oliver thank you very much but the fact
is that
you know we are not at a phase where we
uh can express
views on on this on the subject
there are many many questions which uh
which are raised
in the context of the response to the
pandemic
uh straight across the board we've had
many questions here in the press room on
one part of the strategy related to
vaccines then there's a focus on
the actual vaccination processes that
are taking place in the member states
then there will be
what will we do once once people have
been
have been vaccinated and as
stefan has just said all of this is
subject to subject of discussions with
member states there will be a next
discussion
next week during a vtc of of leaders we
are going to prepare for that discussion
of course
but we are uh we are not in a position
at the stage
to discuss our thinking on
on these on this specific um on this
specific issue i'm sorry
if we can come now to your next question
on vaccines
yeah sorry sorry to uh argue with so
many issues today
it's the last one for today strictly
speaking it's not about vaccines it's
rather about
traveling and the crisis on the 19th of
november after the
one of the most recent uh video
conferences of the leaders president
from the line
said quote our goal is that we will be
ready with the passenger locator form
until the end of the year so the you
know the
the digital form that people have to
fill out before they travel so that
can be traced uh and put under
quarantine and so forth
uh can you tell us where we are with
that because i think so far there's no
single european passenger locator form
yet and what are the reasons
uh if there are any for um
for the delay thank you
um i believe this is uh for
christian but i'm not quite sure anymore
christian
now it works well i can tell you
the latest that i that i have on this
but maybe stefan has
has more to add
i have more general comment that
passenger locator forms help
member states of course to undertake
risk assessment of arrivals and enable
contact raising so they are
important tools and the council has
agreed to work towards such a common
digital
european passenger locate the form and
work has been underway
since july to develop this approach so
that the common
system can be put in place so work is in
full swing on a platform for the
exchange of data between the digital
passenger locator from systems of member
states
with the purpose to facilitating data
exchange between member states and to
enable
also cross-border contact tracing
each eu member state would have access
only to their
national data and of course full respect
of applicable data protection
rules would have to be ensured i have
personally not
a concrete timeline at hand but maybe
stefan has something more to add there
stefan is there anything we can add on
the timeline
i think you know at this stage no but
allow me to
get back to oliver i will look into the
actual
timer indeed of the work i believe work
has been progressed
in in a very important way but i will
have to come back on this
thank you thank you let's continue on
the issue
of um well let's say the response to the
pandemic
more generally from a health uh
perspective
please only keep your hand raised if it
is on
this and we have i believe heta
hasinen
hello yes hello thank you heta hassan
from the finnish news agency
um i have a question on vaccinations so
a prime minister sana marines and the
literature commission president
wonderlion yesterday and urged the
commission to speed up the distribution
of vaccines
so i would like to hear what is the
commission's reaction to this letter
and is there anything that commission
good to or is already doing in order to
speed up the vaccinations
thank you thank you very much look i'm
not aware
of this of this letter we will have to
check whether the letter has been
received or whether it has been aired to
the media before
we have we have received it and
and then we will of course and answer
the letter
in um in due time as to
the vaccination process in general
well you have heard the many many
answers that we have given here in the
press room
on the issue of the organization both of
the purchase of vaccines
and then the vaccination process
and there was a hearing as well this
morning of santa galina
in the envy committee in parliament
where she provided
many answers on this
david you have the floor if it's on
related issues uh thanks eric
it's just about the uh college
commissioner's plan visit to
portugal on friday and whether in the in
the context of a possible
uh lockdown if this is still considered
prudent if there was a decision
might be taken that that it's not wise
to travel in bulk
uh in group uh at this time
commissioners don't really travel in
bulk they travel
indeed in a group as we've said
precisely because of the
of the situation the health situation
the number of members of the college who
will be traveling
to portugal has been reduced a
delegation will therefore be a small
delegation and obviously
we are working with our portuguese hosts
to ensure
that the visit takes place taking into
account and respecting
all of the social distancing and other
health measures that are required
in view of the situation
yes good morning thank you for the floor
it's just a question about
vanilla because i've seen that you have
concluded explore
exploratory talks for the vaccine with
this eighth
company in your portfolio i would like
to have
if it is possible a bit more details
how many doses are you thinking about to
purchase and also if you can update us
and with how many companies are you
holding exploratory talks to get more
vaccines
thank you steven
um thank you very much for this question
do you hear me yes i think so
um well as far as this um the the
finalization of the exploratory talks
with valeneva is concerned we agreed in
this context
on the reservation of 30 million doses
with the option to buy
an additional 30 million dollars so 30
plus 30
meaning 60 million doses we have as i
explained in the beginning uh concluded
contracts with six
um companies and we have uh
finalized exploratory talks with two
companies
novavax and now also valeneva
and that's what i can say in terms of
the ongoing work with the different
pharmaceutical companies the objective
always is
to establish a diversified portfolio
with different companies
and different technologies thank you
thank you follow-up question from
tomaszew
yes very short uh just to know if you're
holding exploratory talks with
other companies i don't know i don't
want to know how many but
are you holding exploratorical talks
with other companies
thank you i i think just if i need to
answer this question
yes no indeed what i can say is what i
have just said we are having um
we finalize find um exploratory talks
with two companies
we have concluded contracts with six
we're not in the habit of
naming companies with whom we may still
have
uh negotiations or not the situation now
is that exploratory talks have been
finalized with two companies
novavax and vanilla and we have
contracts with six of us thank you
thank you i pass the floor to bacht
still on vaccines vaccination etc
thanks uh eric um
the commission is negotiating with
moderna for on a second contract is it
correct that modena is seeking a price
twice as high
as with the first contract and if yes
what are the reasons
i don't believe that we will go into any
discussion on
ongoing negotiations stefan
indeed we have no comments on on
negotiations whether ongoing or not and
we also as you know but we don't have
comments on
prices prices are covered by
confidentiality clauses which
has been explained on numero numerous
occasions
in this press meeting room so we do not
comment on that either
thank you lucas
can you hear me yes go ahead
ecdc informed me yesterday that in
collaboration with member states and
the european commission is currently
establishing a system of to monitor
vaccine deployment
in the european union so could you give
us more detail about this system
how it will work and when it will be
established
and my second question could you present
data how many people
were already vaccinated in european
union thank you
stefan thank you very much
this question was also raised by the way
in today's hearing with
um mrs santagalina and i would invite
you to
consult or check out the website of the
european parliament where you will find
the answers of mrs gallina who indeed
refers to the fact that such a system
is being developed with ecdc and which
would allow on the basis of
regular monitoring of the member state
situation to have a better idea
on the state of the vaccinations but
again i invite you to
check out the replies given by mrs
galina on
that occasion thank you
i believe janis has a question as well
mike source
no it's not working today for some
reason
go ahead again try again
go ahead no yes no it's working yep okay
uh uh it's a question about the uh
investigation
uh by olaf of uh frontex uh i wanted to
ask if
sorry it is sorry yes but we're on
vaccines and vaccination
so if you don't mind we're done with
vaccines okay
i've asked people only to keep their
hand raised yourself vaccines we'll come
back to you afterwards
um i see one further hand raised
i suppose on vaccines and angela
yes angela yes this time i get it right
yes good morning yes my question
is on vaccines then i have another
question on italy but maybe i can do it
later um vaccines
following the phone call between angela
merkel
and vladimir putin on the production of
vaccines
are there any plans to open exploratory
talks with the
russian company for the sputnik
vaccines also for for for using it in
in europe besides hungary uh
which is the only european country who
is
that is using the uh the russian vaccine
thank you stefan
thank you very much angela on the on
this um russian
vaccine candidate i can only tell you
that this stage talks are ongoing
between the company
and emma the company has not yet
submitted or
has not submitted a request for a market
authorization
but as i said emma is in context in
exploratory talks i would say with
the russian vaccine developer and that
is the stage
we are at thank you
thank you now i do not see any further
questions
and i will read out the question from
michelle vindey who also has problems
today
it seems with his mic
so his question in germany a group of
linguists has chosen the commission's
creation returned sponsorship as a
non-word
nonsense word for the year 2020.
according to the jury
it is cynical and euphemistic what is
your reaction on that
this is a question i believe for
adelbere
indeed and thank you for for this
question
return sponsorship is a is a new policy
concept
and therefore it uh it may indeed
um uh raise questions of of
comprehension
uh we've been we've tried uh in our
communication on the impact on migration
and asylum
to be very transparent as to what what
this concept
means and implies so when it comes to
the question of whether this is
a term that is cynical or euphemistic
maybe i can
simply recall some some basics of the
policy and the fact that
first of all returns are a very
important aspect of good migration
management
and when somebody doesn't have the right
to stay in the in the eu
they need to return of course in full
compliance with fundamental rights and
and the the dignity and
return sponsorship is a way in which
when a member state
is not able to itself return
the people who need to be returned from
their territory
they can request they can receive
assistance from
other member states which also then
creates additional space in the
reception system of the
member state that that receives
assistance and therefore that also
creates um
that is also a tangible sign of uh
solidarity between member states and
contributes to good migration management
in europe um
of course if you have uh or indeed if
anyone has any further questions about
return sponsorships we're very happy to
explain this concept further
thank you i think that's a good change
way to janis's question
on frontex janis you have the floor
great thank you eric uh yes my my
question is
uh a can you tell us if the
investigation
by olaf or frontix is related in any way
to the allegations of
pushbacks uh on the greek border with
turkey
and the possible frontex involvement in
them
and secondly does the executive director
of frontex retain the confidence and the
support of the commission
thank you albert
thank you janice um i i think you will
uh you will understand that i am
not in the position to comment in any
way on the content or the context of the
investigation by olaf the the olive
spokesperson has confirmed the existence
of of this investigation but um
i am not able to provide any further
add further information uh of course as
in the case of any
investigation by olaf of any european
body we expect full
full cooperation as to the question of
the confidence in the executive director
yes we are confident that with the
the processes that uh
are set up by the management board and
with the cooperation of the executive
director
all the issues that are currently being
discussed can be addressed
constructively
and the commission is willing to work on
this with the management board and the
executive director
questions for adelberg on migration
related issues
today i see one hand raised yogi
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
o
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
please don't keep your hand raised if
it's a competition question
angela you have another question on
competition
no it's not in competition it's about
italy i don't know if i can do it now or
you can well i don't see any other hand
raised so we will consider the
competition chapter closed go ahead
okay thank you eric italy is entering a
new face of
political instability today is the day
in which the
formal government crisis could be open
i i know you don't want to comment on
national issues
political issues usually but maybe this
could be a different
uh case as italy has the responsibility
of the recovery fund
or for more than 200 billions
euros so has the biggest part
in this and so a problem of political
instability
in in italy could be a european affair
because if
italy doesn't succeed with the recovery
fund the
recovery fund is will not do well and so
it could be a european problem i
i that's why i wanted to ask a comment
on this thanks
thank you but you're absolutely right
that we do not comment on the political
situation
um within the the member states
um we are working with the italian
authorities
that are in place and will continue to
do so and we have full trust
in the fact that italy will
do its utmost to present
and roll out a national recovery plan
in order to benefit from the european
funds of next generation eu
when they are when they are available
and we have no further comment to make
on this
are there other questions for us today
i do not see any so let me thank you for
your
participation and i hope to see you
again
tomorrow thank you